في البدايه من متاعب تيك توك التي لا يبدو
انها لا تنتهي ولن تنتهي قريبا اخر
الاخبار البيت الابيض يريد ان يتم حظر
التطبيق عن كل الاجهزه التابعه للحكومه في
غضون 30 يوما لتفاصيل رئاسه الامريكيه
اكدت ان البيت الابيض امر كل الادارات
والوكالات التابعه للحكومه بازاله تيك توك
من اجهزتها والمهله 30 يوما فقط السبب هو
المخاوف الامنيه الدائمه جهه استخدام
الصين لهذا التطبيق من اجل الحصول على
المعلومات او ربما اختراق الحكومات الخبر
نفسه ولكن من بلد اخر كندا اقدمت على نفس
الخطوه تماما وتطبيق محظور اعتبارا من امس
فالمفوضيه الاوروبيه بدورها كانت ايضا
حضرت ايضا تطبيق على اجهزتها منذ الاسبوع
الماضي
يعني قصه تيك توك قضيه لم تنتهي اليوم
زادت المخاوف الامريكيه من هذا التطبيق
الذي يفترض بانه للتسليه بسبب المنطاد
الصينيين من يعني بدات وليست المره الاولى
يعني من ايام الرئيس الامريكي السابق نون
الترامب ودائما في تحضيرات من مساله تطبيق
تيك توك انه هو عم يتجسس علينا ويخترق
بيانات مستخدمين ونضف الى ذلك ايضا تلفون
هواوي يعني كمان هذه الشركه الصينيه ايضا
كمان تمت توثيق بياناته تسريبات بانها
تخترق ايضا هناك خطر على الامن القومي
الامريكي كذلك في الامر ان الصين نفسها
تبدو بعيده عن تيك توك وتعتمد على تطبيق
محل يدعوين كنا قد ناقشناه سابقا وهو له
قوانين خاصه ولحمايه المستخدم وتقليل بعض
الاضرار يعني باختصار تيك توك الصين شيء
وتيك توك العالم شيء اخر بعباره اخرى
الصين تحمي الصينيين من تيك توك وتحمي
الحكومه ايضا وكانت الصين شككت في التجسس
من مده بعيده
طينه داخل الصين هو تطبيق مشابه بالمزايا
وباختلاف جوهري واحد هو باستخدام وضع
المراهقين الذين تقل اعمارهم عن 14 عاما
وحسب الخبراء فان الخوارزميه بين تطبيقين
مختلفه اختلافا كبيرا فتطبيق توين يعزز
المحتوى العلمي والتعليمي والتاريخي في
الصين